Alors bonjour à tous,
nous sommes ici, euh à Rome au euh
congrès du parti socialiste européen,
avec 1 grosse délégation euh
française pour euh. Voter pour le manifesto,
le programme du parti socialiste
européen dans le cas des élections européennes.
Et puis pour désigner euh.
Nicolas Smith comme notre picson candidat,
notre candidat commun,
celui qui va porter justement
les combats qui sont présents euh dans le manifesto.
Aujourd'hui. C'est 1 moment
très important puisque toute la famille socialiste
est réuni à Rome pour définir le robe qu'on souhaite,
1 robe sociale, 1 robe plus juste,
1 robe écologique,
1 robe de la justice et de l'état de droit,
1 robe qui accueille les migrants.
Et donc aujourd'hui
on a toute cette famille socialiste qui justement
va se réunir pour faire barrage à l'extrême droite
au Parlement européen.
Et donc en route pour le neuf/06,
en route pour avoir 1 robe qui soit
finalement de gauche !